all right let's begin here uh the annual
women's March focusing this year on
legal abortion rights watch
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thousands of people took part in
demonstrations held in dozens of cities
across the country yesterday they
rallied on the 50th anniversary of the
Roe versus Wade decision that the
Supreme Court overturned last summer
eliminating the constitutional right to
abortion in Madison Wisconsin one
demonstrator explained why they turned
out in below freezing temperatures and I
believe that this is not only for today
but this is for our future generations
and the future is female
at a rally in Tallahassee Florida vice
president Kamala Harris said President
Biden had signed a memorandum aimed at
removing legal barriers to providers
that prescribe abortion medication the
woman's March follows Fridays March for
Life wash in Washington D.C which is a
yearly anti-abortion rights
demonstration still a hot button issue
feels on both sides turning out in full
force always always